اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من الجليل الاعلى
اهلا بكم عشرات الشهداء والجرحى في قصف
اسرائيلي كثيف على مدينه غزه وخان يونس
وبيت حانون وزاره الصحه في غزه تعلن
استشهاد
142 فلسطينيا خلال الساعات ال4 الماضيه
ووسائل اعلام اسرائيليه تقول ان اداره
بايدن وبخت حكومه نتنياهو بسبب استمرار
ارتفاع عدد القتلى
المدنيين الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل جندي
واصابه 19 في معارك غزه خلال الساعات ال4
الماضيه كتائب القسام تقول انها قصفت موقع
كيسوفيم بالصواريخ واوقعت عشرات الجنود
الاسرائيليين بين قتيل وجريح وسرايا القدس
تعلن استهداف نقاط تمركز لجنود واليات
الاحتلال شرق مدينه غزه ووسط القطاع وجنت
يقول انه ليس هناك حل كامل لجيوب المقاومه
في
غزه اتساع نطاق الخلافات في اوساط النخبه
الحاكمه في اسرائيل بشان الحرب على غزه
عضو مجلس الحرب جادي ايزنكوت يحمل نتنياهو
اسباب الفشل قبل السابع من اكتوبر وبعده
ويؤكد ان الاتفاق مع حماس وحده قد يضمن
تحرير الاسرى ومصدر في الطاقم الوزاري
الامني المصغر يقول ان الحرب لا مستقبل
لها وان نتنياهو يماطل لكسب الوقت وزعيم
المعارضه يدعو الى تغيير نتنياهو
بسرعه عقب اقتحامها طول كرم وقتلها ثمانيه
فلسطينيين واصابه واعتقال العشرات قوات
الاحتلال تقتحم بلدات عده في نابلس ورام
الله و ت لحم ونادي الاسير يقول ان عدد من
اعتقلهم الاحتلال من الفلسطينيين في الضفه
الغربيه منذ السابع من اكتوبر تجاوز
6000 الى
اللقاء